okay this is a sequence that has
everything it's got mystery it's got a
simple definition great music it's
called the inventory sequence and it was
invented by a guy called Joseph rosenko
and it goes like this we're gonna build
up a sequence every so often
we will pause and take an inventory of
it
and repeat I'm going to start off
here's what we have so far
blank paper
and I ask you how many zeros can you see
zero so we write down
we have zero zeros and when we see a
zero we have to take stock again we take
a new inventory because we're missing
something okay
okay so now
we say brady how many zeros do we see
huh I can see one
so we have one zero Brady how many ones
can I see well I can see one one so we
have one one how many twos can I see
zero twos
okay when we get to a zero we have to
take inventory again how many zeros do
we see two zeros how many ones do we see
two how many twos do we see well we
didn't have any but now we have two twos
so we have two twos and how many threes
do we see well I don't see any threes we
have zero threes time to take stock we
got to a zero how many zeros do we see
one two three three zeros how many ones
one two and how many twos do we have
well we have one two three four twos oh
so the inventory is taking stock as it
grows as well
that's what makes it interesting and
then we keep going how many threes do we
have well I can see one three so we have
one three how many fours well there's a
four so we have one four how many fives
zero fives we get to a zero time to take
stock how many zeros do we have one two
three four how many ones one two three
four how many twos one two three four
two
how many threes
I can only see one so one three how many
fours well there was one there but we
now have three more so we have four
fours and how many fives
none and that's how it goes the next
line it always starts with N because we
will each row gives us a zero now we
have one two three four five zeros so
the first entry of each row is zero one
two three four five six and so on and
the number of ones and twos and threes
grows in a rather irregular way and if
you were to look at a plot you can see
they're in groups and the groups
correspond to the rows the chunks of the
sequence that we're building up and it
always starts with the nth chunk begins
with n and then well it goes up and down
the sequence we're looking at is not
just it's the concatenation the
stringing together of all the chunks
this whole thing is the sequence and
what we're drawing actually is a pin
plot officially
so there's one other sequence I've seen
in the past this was Jan ritzim van X
sequence and I did a video for you about
the van X the famous van heck sequence
and I told vanak about this and he made
a plot of the first thousand terms she
was very interesting quite hopeful
here's his graph he went out to a
thousand terms his plot just joined
successive terms it's not a pin plot
like the first one but it looks like
this and we always see it plunged down
to zero for those inventory moments when
it comes down to zero precisely so yes
and he noticed that if you look at the
upper the envelope of these points it's
about square root of 2N
in fact the this is It's a famous
sequence it's the sequence that goes one
one two two two three three three three
four four four four four four where each
number
one appears twice two appears three
times three appears four times four
appears five times n appears n plus one
times it's it and it grows like very
like square root of 2N and that's what
he's drawn in brown here and you can see
it gives you a very good idea of how
fast these things are growing for the
first thousand terms and then he did a
bigger plot ten thousand terms and the
brown line is useless it grows much
faster so it's not doing square root of
2N anymore it's not going square root of
two n it's way bigger than square root
of 2N it just seems to suddenly leap and
then leap again like it doesn't it's odd
it's a reality it's very irregular and
wonderful so and each clump
chain is a a kind of development of the
previous chunk I would like to play it
for you you know any of the sequences in
the ois you click listen and you can
hear them I'm going to play that one on
the grand piano for you or on a Mac or
on a Mac using GarageBand yes
[Music]
[Music]
as it's going along
we're seeing the chunks which are the
rows of the table
and each chunk begins with a Higher and
Higher One higher note than the previous
chunk but then they're rather irregular
and if you look at the picture of the of
the plot of the sequence the garage band
is actually playing you can see it's
divided up into chunks and the cha each
chunk is a little bit like the previous
chunk but keeps changing and they also
get longer each time so I think of this
as variations on a theme like
Beethoven's diabelly variations
where he was diabelli proposed the theme
and Beethoven embroidered it produced a
series of variations on it here we have
the variations but we don't know what
the themes
[Music]
and you can hear when it gets to the end
of a chunk there's a string of low
numbers like the zerosm ones at the end
of that and you can hear them down at
the bottom of the keyboard and then it
starts up again so there's a
well-defined notion of chunk of
variations you could say except we don't
know the theme
[Music]
foreign
you can see it's getting more
interesting as it goes along there's
more variation and you can see it
graphically
the sequence gets more and more
complicated
as you study it and really in the end we
don't know that much about it
Remy siegrist made a plot of the first
10 to the eighth terms 100 million terms
and there's a very interesting structure
this is the same sequence it's just
represented by dots each term is now a
DOT on the piece of paper and you can
see something very strange is happening
this is a hundred million terms and
we're going along and the points sort of
fall on lines
but the lines cross each other this is
very unusual in this kind of sequence
normally the Lions get further and
further apart as we go along What's
Happening Here is the lead is changing
sometimes there'll be more eights than
anything else the Apes will dominate but
then after a while the nines will take
over there'll be more nines and eights
and then maybe after a while the eights
take over again and that's why these
lines are crossing and really this is a
really mysterious sequence it would be
nice to know more about it do you think
there's any value to mathematics in here
I mean this is a recreational sequence
isn't it and you've found a a quirky
thing but do you sometimes think there's
some hidden meaning or depth or
importance to this there could be Maybe
not maybe so
you know one of the things that John
Conway did was to take
what you might say small problems like
this and make theories out of them and
connect them with other things
and I think that's a very good thing to
do
so maybe in itself it's just a sequence
who knows where it will lead
now here's a great sequence for you to
Grapple with courtesy of today's episode
sponsor Jane Street
we've got an infinite pathway with
numbered stones
but each Stone also has a number like
this we've got one one two two three
three four four you get the picture
the red numbers indicate the size of the
leap you can make from each Stone either
forward or back
can't be more or less that's the exact
size
so how many leaps does it take to reach
each Stone on the pathway for example if
you want to reach this Stone well that's
going to take five leaps as you can see
as you aim for Stones further down the
path some very interesting patterns and
problems emerge check out this page on
the Jane Street website to dig deeper
while you're there if you've got a brain
for problems and numbers and stuff like
this you may be the sort of person to
join Jane Street's genius teams around
the world they've got offices in Hong
Kong New York London check out details
on their website there'll be links in
the video description and have some fun
with this infinite pathway
well it was a choice we could put the
six here no no I can't put it there
because that's got neighbor five four
and one I could only put a 10 there aha
you've got to put them in order yes
I've got to build your way up so it's
not what's the highest value can I get
on the board it's what's the highest
value I can get on the board building in
order building in order